hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
i don't know how i got myself into this
but
here i am doing another debunking video
uh
response to danny at gr research uh
today
post a video where he took a
couple of inductors crossover inductors
and put them next to each other
and fed power to one and lo and behold
the other one picked up that uh sound
and played it in the twitter
and he then claimed therefore same
thing's happening to two speaker wires
if they're next to each other
and therefore it is the bad thing
puzzling that he didn't use two speaker
wires
you know he has speaker wires he has his
own fancy speaker wire
why would you do the test with coils and
not speaker wire
there's a huge difference between a
speaker wire and a coil
a coil as you see the wires are wound
and many many turns
and speaker wire normally doesn't have
any many turns in it
and as i'll show later on it makes a
difference so
what he didn't do um we're gonna do
we're gonna test speaker wire
rather than trying to play with
inductors although i'll
i'll show you how you can make your own
inductor out of that so
why don't we switch away from his
browser
and go to my audio precision so i have a
simple setup
where my audio precision all it has is
the
crunchy old nasty zip cord uh
speaker wire and i'm just using my led
lamp as a holder for it
and uh goes from input to output i'm
feeding a four volts which at eight ohms
would be
equivalent to two watts so not a lot of
power
i've said that to be the zero level over
here as i explained in my db
video and if we look in here we'll see
that
we got tiny bit of uh mains hum here
at almost minus 150 db so extremely
small amount of indifference being
picked up
and remember threshold of hearing uh for
our most sensitive region is at -115 so
this is at -150
so definitely not a concern so
now look at what happens when i grab
this wire
and i bring in a mains cable a hefty one
that i use for uh
amplifier testing and it's actually
plugged in at the other end so it's just
this is live
don't lick that end not good for you
um and i hold this next to this and we
see that yeah
lo and behold it does pick up some
interference we're now up to
130 db i've got them pretty parallel
with each other
and but -130 it's still
massively below threshold of hearing
indeed you can go
do this test yourself put that wire next
to it and then stick your ear next to
the speaker see if you can hear any hum
and buzz
i guarantee you will not hear hum and
buzz but uh notice what happens if we uh
loop these things together hopefully the
effect will be there uh
nah i can't get it to really peak any
more than uh
it already does uh there we go
uh so maybe maybe a few more db if we
make an inductor out of it
so even though i'm doing something
you're not supposed to do which is
make an inductor and take a speaker wire
and a mains wire and tightly couple them
make multiple loops you still don't get
there and look at how
sensitive it is to even just location
and movement of this thing
there's no way i can induce any kind of
meaningful
uh noise there now
threshold of hearing uh as i mentioned
is minus 115 db but that minus 115 db
is at two to three kilohertz it is not
at 60 hertz 60 hertz
threshold of hearing is probably minus
uh about plus 70 db spl
so this uh hum needs to be way
up here many many dbs higher
so you can see my cursor before
you need it to be a lot higher for it to
be audible and it's not
remotely remotely so but there's a more
important point in here
we can measure this so when you say hey
there's electromagnetic interference i
just measured it i just showed it to you
you saw that took no work
turn on the analyzer plug in a cable
boom
we're measuring the effect of
interference so
there is no mystery in here as far as
what we can measure yet
danny says that the improvement these
cables provide in
eliminating reducing electromagnetic
interference are not
measurable well we're measuring it he
indeed measured it himself
he was showing the effect going up and
down as he put the two coils next to
each other
so clearly parts of his arguments don't
hold at all
it's this classic issue i see in these
all these high-end tweaks and high-end
ideas
in that they hypothesize a problem
before proving that the problem exists
they go on
and think of a solution to it they need
to verify that the hypothesis is correct
nor verify that the solution is correct
obviously if you don't understand the
problem
you haven't measured it you haven't
quantified how do you know you're
solving it
it can't be just by osmosis you just
sort of of such
vision that you can imagine a problem
and without verifying the problem exists
say hey
you know it's there now he says well the
problem's audible
well great do a control blind listening
test
take a mains cable put it next to the
other cable put on the speaker wire next
to another one without the person
seeing it and see if they can tell the
difference see if they can raise their
hand when you put them next to each
other without seeing and take it away as
if they put their hands down so
listening tests are perfect
love loosening tests hey throw away all
this stuff show me listening tests
but when you show you know fixtures and
supposed measurements well fit for that
i can measure it and my test is more
valid than his because i'm using speaker
wire
and i'm showing you the exact difference
even if it's inaudible
i'm able to show it to you this
instrument
can measure things they're hugely below
threshold of hearing
so it isn't that we can't measure our
measurements are too good
we measure things that are absolutely
inaudible
but the effect is there if i breathe on
this cable
if i just look at it just move it around
notice that that can just the graph
changes
so this is how sensitive it is you think
you can tell that your
stereo sounds different if you just move
the speaker wire a little bit like this
can you hear that difference you cannot
right
yet instrumentation has no trouble
quantifying
exactly what's happening to our signal
and this is relative to two watts
if i make this 100 watts these levels
will shrink even more
yet the instrumentation is happy that's
where we have instrumentation
we can find things that you know with
microscope we can see things that we
can't see with the naked eye
that's what this is there's nothing
weird about it
to say oh doesn't mean anything i don't
look at graphs
well no this graph picks up things
where we can verify a theory indeed we
have a problem
we have interference magnetically on rf
as i showed in my last video
the problem for these folks is that we
can easily then apply psychoacoustics to
this
and say it's not audible you can talk
about all you want
wave your hands put two coils next to
each other have nothing to do with that
speaker wire
but it's not logic it's not science it's
not consistent in itself
you know as i said in my last video if
it's
only audible fine don't show these tests
then
where you take two coils of them next to
each other to say hey just imagine if
these are speaker wires
why do i need to imagine you have
speaker wires put them next to each
other
what was so hard about that well mozart
is that if you put the speaker wires
next to each other
it wouldn't pick up anything you have to
make them two inductors so they have a
strong magnetic coupling anyway
i don't know that you want to stare at
me anymore talking about these
uh topics so i'll go ahead and stop this
uh before it runs too long
see you in the next video bye-bye